[Music]
[Applause]
877 3dp show email address dp at
danpatrick.com always great to talk to
booger mcfarland espn nfl and college
football analyst and part of uh two
super bowl champion teams booger joining
us on the program good morning booger
how are you
dp what's up buddy how are we doing well
we were talking about great running
backs in college and how many carries
the body has in it you know that
christian mccaffrey banged up last year
got hurt last night i wonder if we're
going to see the same for zeke elliot
like
teams pay them and you want to use them
but then you also have to be careful
with how much you use them what what
happened to the running back position
well i think you guys are onto something
with the carries um you know i i go back
to the guys at alabama remember uh
ingram and richardson and they just ran
those guys into the ground and
richardson was never the same yeah uh
once he got in the nfl and and you know
if you look at a guy like naji harris uh
who's in pittsburgh now nazi wasn't used
a lot early on in his career by his
senior year he was and so
i'm interested to do kind of a case
study to see how he fares as far as the
injury uh injuries are concerned i think
you could say the same for leonard
fournette i mean les miles never met a
run he didn't like he ran leonard
fournette into the ground so i i i agree
there's only so many carries and i think
nfl coaches have to be smart because you
know some of these old school coaches
want to practice full speed all week and
you know essentially you're playing two
to three games as far as the wear and
tear now i know you're not getting hit
but you know when you're running full
speed full speed is full speed whether
it's on wednesday or sunday so
yeah these these new school coaches have
to do a better job of getting guys to
sunday that's where guys like kyle
shanahan
and sean mcvade i think they do a good
job with some of these veteran players
because they're kind of a newer school
they really are not concerned as much
about having two and a half three-hour
practices during the week
i'm wondering if miami the u in 2001
didn't have the best group of running
backs for one season
clinton portis willis mcgahy frank gore
naji davenport
uh that one was good uh take a look at i
don't have it in front of me what about
georgia when they had gurley sonia
michelle and there was another one they
had so georgia maybe it was chubb chubb
was a freshman yeah chubb was a freshman
um but they they had chubbs sony
michelle deandre swift at the same time
usc had reggie bush and lindale white
oklahoma state had thurman thomas barry
sanders smu eric dickerson craig james
um auburn in 2004 cadillac williams and
ronnie brown
arkansas 2007 darren mcfadden felix
jones and peyton hillis
who who's the best running back you ever
faced in college
wow uh college i would probably say
stephen davis remember the big running
back from auburn stephen davis yeah he
was he was alone to deal with because
not only was he fast man but the dude
was shooting 35 240 pounds um
yeah him and i'm trying to think who
else um
yeah he was about the only one you know
because i didn't go against guys like
james stewart and aaron hayden edward
tennessee i i didn't i didn't get a
chance to see those guys i missed those
guys during the sec cycle
do you think that we'll see a running
back drafted in the top 10 over the next
10 years
no because i think that position has
kind of i'm not going to say it's
devalued but you realize
even if you get one in the later rounds
the talent gap is not going to be
astronomical and so i i think therefore
why would you waste a top 10 pick on a
running back uh i.e leonard fournette
even ezekiel elliott has only given you
about two or three prime years and now
uh i think tony pollard is a more
explosive back in dallas so
i doubt it maybe at the end of the first
round you may get one kind of like a
naji harris around 22 23 but i
definitely don't think you're going to
see one in the in the top 10 picks
because the quarterbacks are too
valuable offensive alignment are too
valuable defensive lineman are too
valuable and running backs come a dime a
dozen
yeah but why is it that you can always
find a running back
you don't say that maybe you say it
about offensive linemen but it feels
like you can always find a running back
because i think when you look at the at
the skill position and how guys are
groomed and and how guys are created in
college and high school everyone wants
to play running back so so you get a lot
of the best athletes playing that
position and so the
the volume of running backs to choose
from uh is more plentiful than say a
great quarterback because you can only
have one quarterback on the team that's
going to play at one time or a great
offensive tackle like who wants to play
offensive tackle in high school like
none of the girls want to date the
offensive tackle we all want the guy
that touches the football and runs the
ball so i think that has something to do
with it plus i mean let's face it this
is a 707 sport now dan it's quarterbacks
and receivers and tight ends even a
tight end like a like a george kittle
who's a two-way tight end that can block
and catch like those guys are being
phased out a little bit like blocking is
not cool anymore it's hey throw me the
ball let me catch let me play dvd where
i can pick the balls off and go to the
end zone so
it is a true 707 sport now that happens
to have a few defensive and offensive
linemen in it
you can only watch one this weekend
chargers chiefs buccaneers rams packers
niners
uh to me that's easy it's gonna be bucks
rams because i think that if both teams
play at a high level you could be
looking at an nfc championship game and
i really want to see what matthew
stafford is going to do because dan
think about the narrative is matthew
stafford a a good player or should i say
a great player that was in a bad
organization in detroit and never could
kind of get his
his just due or was he a good player
that just never could get the
organization over the top we're gonna
find out because he said not his words
mine he said i want to play in big games
i want to be in games that matter well
guess what matthew steffer you got your
you got your wish buddy because this is
a huge game tom brady the buccaneers
arguably the most talented team in
football coming to your house okay
traveling across the country and you're
gonna stare the goat toe-to-toe so we're
gonna find out whether matthew stafford
can take the first step
into what he talked about which is
playing in these huge games
i felt like the media overreacted week
one with the packers and aaron rodgers i
didn't expect them to beat the saints i
didn't expect them to play that poorly
but i think they overreacted in beating
the lions because i expected them to
beat the lions i think this is probably
more of a litmus test uh
you know facing the niners on the road
than the first two weeks what do you uh
uh how do you break down this game
here's here's the way i look at the at
the packers um the packers are not as
bad as they were in week one they're not
as good as they were in week two uh if
you look at their defense their defense
is not as good zadaria smith he's
injured so they don't have any pass rush
now if you don't have any passers what
does that mean then that means the back
end of your defense the secondary is
going to be exposed and we saw tom brady
expose the secondary in the nfc
championship game well guess what other
than jair alexander this is not a very
good secondary so yeah their defense is
not as good and aaron rodgers let's face
it he told you he didn't play well week
one didn't play well at all so when i
look at the packers
i think they ultimately can get back to
where they were
but they are nowhere near there now
they're not running the ball as well
david baciari is not there that left
tackle he's out uh corey linsley who's
the center who's it was a very good
center uh he's now in uh in la with the
chargers so the reality of it is it's
not the same team it's going to take
this team just a little time to jail and
get where they want to go um
i don't know if they are as physical as
san francisco wants to be see because
the last couple times we've seen green
bay san francisco then it's been like
hey let me take my little brother behind
the shed and just beat the hell out of
it like it's been a physical blood but
think about jimmy garoppolo they beat
the packers and he only threw like 10
passes that game remember so can can can
green bay step up to the physical
uh part of the football game that's what
i want to know because if they can't
then in the back of their minds
regardless of what the rest of their
season looks like in the back of their
mind they're constantly going to say
yeah
we're good but if we see that team i
don't know if we can physically step up
or physically handle what they do to us
you got the eagles and the cowboys
you'll be in dallas for uh monday night
um what concerns do you have with the
cowboys
they steal that defense think about this
america's team
all the money jerry got and the only
thing we're talking about in dallas is a
rookie defensive player in michael
parsons like where's the help demarcus
lawrence's hurry the secondary steal
isn't great um your best defensive
player right now is a rookie that's a
lot to ask of a rookie now the offense
is going to be really good let's face it
the offensive line led by zach martin
hall of famer they're good uh that
prescott if you don't think he's a top
five to seven quarterback in football
you need to give up your credentials the
wide receivers when they go when they go
three wide receivers with gallup uh
amari cooper cd lam there's not a better
three in football so the offense is
going to be good but then it's still the
same question can they stop people
consistently especially with a rookie as
your best defensive player
yeah i just wonder they it feels like
when you play for the cowboys you're
you're you're better than what you
really are that that all of a sudden hey
you play for the cowboys you got to be
good and i've been saying all along when
they went 13-3
they were hiding a lot of that you know
defensive ineptitude because they kept
the defense off the field therefore when
they were on the field you know they
were able to do some things now
you know can they replicate that can
they be that kind of team that wins 13
games therefore you don't count you
don't need to count on the defense that
much almost like the chiefs
think about week one dan that threw for
400 yards
and they lost
okay that threw it 50 times and they
lost think about week two
they actually ran the ball more than
that through they won so what you're
saying is the cowboys need to know how
to play complimentary football like they
need to know how to win games it's not
just a bit like this is not madden this
is not meat friday and we're sitting
around with the playstation 5 playing
video games and eating you know brisket
you actually have to put together a game
plan to play complimentary football so
how do i protect the defense that we all
agree is not very good well maybe that
shouldn't throw it every down
maybe just maybe he shouldn't throw 50
times and so hopefully
um keller moore and mike mccarthy will
figure that out because if they don't if
they don't that could put up video game
numbers but they won't win a lot of
football games
you should stop in for a meet friday one
of these days
i would love to as a matter of fact uh
i'm gonna be coming i'm gonna come to
new york uh early on a friday morning
and i'll land in new york maybe around 9
9 30 and i'll make it a point to come by
i don't even need to be on the show i
just want to come by and eat and just
hang out and watch you do your thing
what do you you tell me what you want as
far as the menu
and uh and we'll we'll
try to prepare that for you
i can tell you right now i am a i am a
brisket
sausage guy like i i don't really need
the sausage with all the cheese and
jalapenos in it just give me some
regular quebos and sausage give me a
nice brisket with a nice smoked ring on
it a little crust i don't need i don't
need it fatty or lean kind of somewhere
in the middle and just all the coke zero
you have and i i'm i'll be as happy as
a cat going outside for the first time
ah
good to talk to you buddy uh have fun
playing golf today thanks for joining us
as always
vp anytime you need me let me know and i
appreciate it buddy thank you very much
that's booger mcfarland you can catch
him in studio college football
throughout the day on saturday nfl prime
time with chris berman on sunday as well
as monday night countdown in dallas week
three on espn